one thing that git is known for is
version control in fact that would be
for some people the first way to
describe it i described git as
protecting code but you could describe
it as protecting versions as well
versions is a thing which drives me
insane when you come and you find
somebody who's called a video dot final
or underscore final because you just
know there's going to be a change to it
and there'll be final final or new final
or final new final what what does git do
it's good to think about things like
that because you would end up with
software doing the same and i had a
friend in the company and they were
producing versions of software and
someone wasn't conforming to the company
style of naming things and was creating
new version 4. new you know and all
these these things but yeah so actually
software has a pretty strong history of
having inversion numbering scheme for
example if you look at the latest
version of chrome or chromium it's like
version 98.0.4758.81
that time of recording yeah at the time
of recording um or that might be the
current version i've been stored which
is when i last updated it but still like
this is so what's that version 98 is the
major one
and then
point zero is the latest minor iteration
of it and then points four seven five
eight is the latest patch to it
um but what they're doing at the same
time is they're
maintaining older versions so you can at
any time if you want to you can install
version 94 of chromium just by going to
their open source community and then
downloading an old version
and if you really want you can um it's
quite interesting with premium you can
see the latest commit that a developer
has put into the chrome repository and
you can download that whether it works
or not you know as a developer you can
download it
but the point is they've created these
versions
and they're using git to manage this
version history
and uh
they are using what's called branches
within git to manage
old versions that they need to update so
there might be like a patch to an old
version which has new feet doesn't have
certain new features of a new one but
someone's using because it's compatible
with something else but it still needs a
security fix absolutely so whenever they
find a vulnerability they say okay we
need to update you know like windows 8
if anybody's still using that we need to
make sure that's secure so they've got
to somehow go back to download the code
for windows 8 make that patch to it and
then release
probably
8.10.75 which is the latest patch to it
and you can see this in like when you
get new release notes you know if you're
on your phone and like netflix updates
to the latest version you get these
release notes saying you know version
17.5.8 has these things fixed and it
will have like a little description of
what they updated
but what they do is they have these kind
of past versions built into what's
called a git branch
so that branch then can then exist
forever and they can you can then switch
your code view to that branch in the
history and say i want to update you
know version 16 in case anyone's still
using it um with this fix
and then commit to that and then okay
let's check out the main branch again
and we'll make updates to the main
branch which is what our main job is
so you find companies use these kind of
product release branches essentially to
store long term
in parallel with the current new updates
other old versions they can update
so in the first video we did we talked
about having like a linear history of
all your
past versions at some point you can say
okay i want to branch that linear
history into a tree
and you can switch between those trees
essentially using the git branch command
one thing you can do first is you can
type in just git branch and it will list
all the things you have and for most
people if they've never created a branch
before that just shows you the main
branch that you're currently on and it
will have a star next to it that's the
one that's showing you
if you wanted to see if you wanted to
create a new branch which is like
for developing a new feature for example
you could type a git branch and then
have a name
and that will create a new branch from
your current points
uh
and then it will be listed if you type
git branch again as being one of the
branches you could switch to do you call
that one new or final yeah new french so
actually that's a really complicated
issue because um teams that are working
on codes there might be 100 developers
and they all might need to create a
temporary branch so they've got to have
some sort of naming scheme so
it's a good point to make while you're
there um
but
so if you then want to work on that
branch then you have to get check out
that branch
so you have to kind of
choose to switch your view from the main
branch and then say okay now i want to
view this new branch
which you might name you it could be
called dev branch
and then what that will do is it will
change your folder view which i
mentioned before to show in the files
that are in that branch that means you
could then add some new files in that
branch
you could then commit them to that
branch then if you get check out the
main you'll see those files disappear
temporarily although they're stored
somewhere in your docket folder as
compressed objects you've chosen to view
the main branch and so it will hide all
the ones that aren't related to the main
branch and then when you get check out
the dev branch it will then bring those
files back to you and show them to you
so it's a it's a kind of handy way of
switching between versions basically so
that means these companies that have
created
uh like a version 4.45 of their software
um
they can if they ever want to switch to
it they check out
you know branch version 0.45
and then they could work on it and then
see those files and they can check out
the main again or whichever one they're
supposed to normally work on we can also
talk about git tag
so git tag is kind of a handy feature
where you can name
a point in your history with a friendly
name
so instead of saying i want to check out
this
hash code of like a past commit
you can say okay there is one point in
time which is when we finished version
4.5
and we can give that a friendly name so
if i ever want to i can say git checkout
4.5 and it will just download 4.5 for me
so it's a way of giving things friendly
names you can use a lot of companies use
like a b in their naming scheme for beta
or rc for a release candidate which is
when they think that this
the updates this branch are almost ready
to show to the public
and then they will show them to like a
certain outlet of potential users who
test things as a release candidate um
and then they will so they'll name it
they'll get tag it with that release
candidate id
so that they can then share a specific
friendly named version with people to
download and companies will have all
sorts of automation scripts which will
take anything that's given a git tag and
compile it as a ready-to-ship product
and test it on a server and then deploy
it to a point where people can download
and automatically update the website to
say there's a new version you could
build all those things in but in
practice the fact that they're named
with git tag as a command is what's
important
so what happens is uh when you first
create a file create file in there and
make my files green just represent
there's a box and i call that version
one at this point git doesn't know
anything about that because you haven't
told it about it so to get get to know
about it we have to do it and i think
mike's going to demonstrate this in a
second
is that
log4j is like milk it's like water it's
everywhere